The solution that they took in Andrew is as follows. Only for logging into
a workstation the user name and password are used. And of course, they have to
be securely communicated to the server Over
insecure links, we'll see how that is
done. But the key point is that username and password is only useful logging in.
Once a user is logged into a workstation, at that point onwards for the
rest of the log-in session, the intent is to use ephemeral IDs and
ephemeral keys But all the subsequent
Venus to vize communication. Recall that Venus
is the process that resides on the
virtual workstation, acting as a surrogate for
the user for file caching. And vize is, of course, the server that
is living inside A secure environment. And this venus-vize communication
happens over insecure links, that's where we going to use ephemeral
ids and keys. So this gives rise to three classes of client-server
interactions. The first interaction is logging
in, imagine you're a student, and you're doing
a course project. What is that you're going to do.
You're going to walk up to a work station and
log in presenting your username and password to the
workstation. And this username and password is going
to be used as the basis for, the client
server communication that let's you authenticate yourself to the
server. Now once you authenticate yourself to the server
what are you going to do, well you want to do a cost project, and for
the cost project you probably need to download
some files to the server. And that requires that
Venus that is running on your workstation establish
an RPC session with the server in order
to fetch the files that you need to
work on for your course project. That's the second
class of client-server communication, establishing an
RPC session. Now once you establish an
RPC session, then you can request the files that you want as a user.
As a student you want certain files to be accessed during this RPC session.
You bring those files and once you brought in the file that you want,
you can close the RPC session, work on your project locally on the workstation.
And once you're done with completing whatever work you needed to do, you
may establish a new RPC session to upload the results,of your work back into the
file server. So the three classes of client-server interactions are logging in,
which happens exactly once for the entire loin
session, and RPC session establishment, which may happen several
times during the time that you're logged into work
station. Every time you decide oh, I want to
fetch a new file. Oh, I want to store
this file back into the server. The third set
of interaction is the actual file system access during
the session. Once this RPC session has been established
by venus with vize, then you as the user,
you may want to work on a particular file
You may open a file. At that point, Venus
will go, using this RPC session, and fetch the
required file and cache it locally for you to
use it, and later on, if you close the
file, at that point, Venus will commit the changes
that you made to the file to the central
file server again. So that's the kind of file system operation
that's the third class of client server interaction. And for both RPC
session establishment, and for the actual access to the file system
during an RPC session, we want to use ephemeral ID's and keys.